we spent a lot of time with modern
warfare 2's early access playstation
beta and went all out from nailing some
sick kill streaks to doing some
myth-busting and experiments and uh
painfully dismembering an enemy with a
drill charge
here's what you need to know to succeed
as you hop into call of duty modern
warfare 2.
[Music]
so right off the bat movement's got some
fun additions this time around if you
are a 2019 modern warfare veteran you
will feel right at home with tactical
sprint and sliding on corners although
you know the motion blur is a little
gnarly at times your mileage will vary
on that sprinting or slowly stocking
your way through areas will feel very
much the same as past modern warfare
games however there are some distinct
changes especially if you want to do
your best mission and possible
impersonation dolphin diving and hanging
from ledges or shooting over ledges are
a thing now i've messed around with both
of them and dolphin diving is pretty
clutch if you're like me and you didn't
know what dolphin diving was at first
it's basically taking a giant leap
forward and going from the air straight
to prone doesn't actually involve real
dolphins so anna now i use it when
rounding corners when you need to hold
down a long lane rather than push
through or when you're under fire as an
escape mechanism and it's worked out
pretty well for me the time to kill or
ttk in the beta is just for giving
enough that you can escape if you react
quickly there's some pretty cool utility
with dolphin diving like diving out of
windows and potentially leaping over
some of the low rubble in terrain if
you're really feeling like a daredevil
you could take a giant leap off a roof
by dolphin diving there are drawbacks
for example it does take a second before
you can ready your weapon and start
firing again hanging from ledges is kind
of odd and then it seems like you're
doing your best impersonation of a dark
souls 3 minion you can't shoot your
weapons unless you have a pistol as a
secondary and even then the angle feels
like a little odd however it is a pretty
neat way to clamber out of sight and
potentially do some parkour of a
building like a shortcut of sorts it's
balanced by the fact that you have to
get off the ledge to reload the perk
system has been a thing for countless of
past call of duties and a lot of them
like overkill or scavenger reappear in
modern warfare 2 but perks are built out
in packages that you earn over time so
unlike modern warfare 2019 you don't
have to choose between kill streaks and
stacking perks like you did with the
specialist system perks are set up in a
scorestreak system now so the more
points you get the more perks you can
activate so kills assists defending a
capture point and many more tactics will
help you become a more powerful force to
go against one standout perk that i
think everyone should look into at least
early on in the meta is the self revive
as your ultimate perk since combat is so
fast and frenetic it can be easy to
forget to double check that the target
you eliminated is actually dead and not
just down trust me i've had countless
instances where self-revive proved to be
really clutch
there's also other advantages to using
self-revive for one you can potentially
crawl to safety if you're downed at a
distance teammates can revive you
instead and if they choose to do so you
can be revived even faster still need to
test this but if a teammate revives you
i want to say there's still a chance
that you can use your self revive again
if you become down to the same life i
mean what i do know is that if you are
able to pull off a successful self
revive your killstreak count won't be
reset at least until you die again but
all in all it is my personal favorite
ultimate although eagle-eyed players
might prefer one of the other ones i
know there's a perk that gives you a
better mini map for example so it's up
to you some other perk packages to
consider are how each can combine the
different perks to feed off each other
in a synergetic way
so extra tactical and resupply perks
that means you've got throwable gear for
days
a varied arsenal means a deadly arsenal
and you can use gadgets to give you that
extra umph when engaged with enemies let
me start with the funny [ __ ] right off
the bat there is a blow up dummy
it can also kill you
amazing seriously though the blow up
decoy dummy is not a joke and it caught
me off guard several times thinking that
it was a real dude definitely worth
trying out and faking out a couple of
enemies and getting them to fire which
makes them pop up on your radar 2 if
you're clever about it only thing to
consider is that it's one of the few
gadgets with an extremely long recharge
time
pro tip the dummy will always orient
towards an approaching enemy to let you
know where they are coming from there
are some excellent gadgets to keep an
eye out for the trophy system makes its
return and it still stops an airstrike
killstreak like in modern warfare 2019.
seriously i got the receipts right here
there is a personal radar that you can
toss out like a landmine that will ping
enemies in a decent range near your
vicinity and there's even a ddos now the
ddos is my personal favorite because it
can do a few things like it for one
tracks enemies within a certain range
although i'm not sure if each bar
signifies one or two enemies but using
the ddos though it's kind of like a
counter uav but it includes other
gadgets as you can disable the tech your
opponent is probably using against you
an added bonus it fudges up their radar
too when when some other quick notes on
gadgets there is a deployable barricade
which is good if you've got a heavy
weapon like an lmg and you like to mount
it on barriers walls or floors while
providing you some nifty cover like on
the roof in the farm map it can also
protect you from a mine going off if you
happen to time it right loadout crates
are a thing if you played battlefield
2042 the specialist angel brings down a
loadout crate for you and your team as
well same thing here except you know in
the beta we've been playing mainly 6v6
modes and maps and the loadout crate is
honestly useless
considering that you can just swap your
loadout on respawn like what's the point
you need ammo all right we'll use the
scavenger perk or even an ammunition box
gadget or even grabbing a weapon from
your dead enemy's body these are all
better alternatives in my opinion now
this will probably be more useful on
battle maps when you need to get a
launcher out to stop kill streaks but if
you are in a pinch you can always use it
as cover an interesting rainbow six
siege style gadget is the camera which
is good for watching your back or
domination points but it has a few
drawbacks for example spotting enemies
doesn't seem to give you any scorestreak
points like even a little although i can
see some use for the cameras in the
hostage mode i really don't see much
advantage in something like team
deathmatch or domination modes that you
know the vast majority of cod fans will
be playing the camera does give in
audible ping when an enemy passes it so
it is good for watching your back or
letting you know when an enemy team is
approaching say a domination point or
hostage now that's all good for gadgets
but check out some of these nades man
you've got your classics like semtex
frags smokes and it's like getting a
pepperoni pizza you just can't go wrong
with them but may i introduce you to the
[ __ ] drill charge the first
time i encountered the drill charge was
on the wrong end i mean i was minding my
own business on the second floor and
then blew up and only from the killcam
that i see how the drill charge worked
and god it is fun
it can go through normal cover which is
really cool and it's really good at
blowing up rooms with campers you can
even directly drill charge enemy players
and yeah it looks gnarly another really
cool nade are the shock sticks destiny
fans that use lightning grenades might
recognize the way shock sticks work
for starters they're able to stick on
any surface like a trip mine and will
keep shooting out bolts of electricity
ready to zap anyone even you within
range you can shoot one if they get
thrown at you i mean i like to use them
as a defense measure giving me time to
escape but they're also really great for
preventing enemies from pushing up on
you if you are weak however i have seen
countless teammates use them to breach a
certain point
anyone that gets shocked will have their
fingers seized up on the trigger firing
wildly which is a neat touch the
progression of weapon unlocks is both
easy but it's also confusing as hell not
sure how much of this will change post
beta but i did find that i was unlocking
a boatload of attachments at the end of
a good game and quickly mastering and
unlocking weapon archetypes within a few
hours at most sometimes as fast as a
couple rounds even the problem though
unlocking weapons is confusing because
there's no rhyme or reason and the ui is
just so cluttered it's easy to get lost
so here's a quick explainer there are
new weapon parts known as receivers
which are the base of a certain
archetype like an lmg smg and so on
certain attachments that you unlock are
universal and can be carried over to
other receivers this helps take out the
annoyance of having to grind to unlock
the same red dot side or barrel over and
over again the problem that progression
tree doesn't always make sense if you go
to the progress bar at the top near the
gunsmith you will notice that to unlock
the m16 for example you have to get
progress on the m4 which okay fair
enough but then a
lmg
what
or you know take the hurricane smg for
example an incredibly dominant early
metagun in my opinion that shines
particularly in hip-fire situations but
you know it's an excellent all-arounder
type gun so you want it right and to
unlock the hurricane you have to spend
painful rounds messing not with other
smgs or even an ar but an awful first
fire battle rifle of sorts it just
doesn't make sense so viewers beware
keep an extra eye out on the progression
tabs if there is a gun down the line
that you're hoping to unlock sooner
because it is not as natural or
intuitive as you might hope
now a few things to keep in mind while
you're shooting specifically if you've
got a heavy lmg or another weapon with a
high capacity mag in your hands
normally you could reload cancel by
swapping to a secondary if you're in a
dire situation but that's not the case
here if you start a reload and then swap
to your sidearm and eventually swap back
you will just pick up at the old
animation something to consider for sure
if you know your weapon reload will take
several seconds oh and some thermal
sides still see through smoke from smoke
grenades which is
i mean kind of scummy but oh so
effective to shoot enemies that can't
see you back you know modern warfare 2
does have some pretty neat qol stuff
added to the fray as well
you've got some wicked cool execution
animations if you sneak up on an enemy
but the animations actually change
depending on if your enemy is
self-reviving or not
i've been on the receiving end of being
strangled to death from an execution so
you'll have to take my word for it
ps5 and even ps4 pro players have an fov
slider which is really nifty so i'm
confident we can expect the same for our
xbox gamers in the comments
fov sliders are a good thing and as a pc
main myself it does go a long way in
affecting my gameplay some other quick
notes is that there's a pretty solid ttk
not too fast not too haloey you can
escape properly if you disengage and the
6v6 map so far offers some pretty
interesting engagements on both high and
low vantage points the perk packages
mean you don't have to sacrifice your
kill streaks for specialist boons and
with the weightier grounded guns every
engagement feels exciting
this being an infinity ward game every
map has tons of climbing routes and
areas or angles that you can learn to
use you know i mentioned execution
animations earlier but there's even
other fun attention to detail moments
like swapping to a pistol from the
hurricane smg and doesn't stow away the
gun entirely you actually still hold the
smg in your left hand so you can do your
best rambo impersonation so cod now has
a third person mode which will break
down the why of it all later but what
you do need to know now is that it is
not really a true third person mode
because you can still ads at any time
and it goes back into the traditional
first person perspective but that being
said there are some neat advantages that
you should be mindful of for example in
destiny people would always equip swords
in pvp so it would take them out to a
third person perspective letting them
peek around walls without actually
poking out into the line of fire
three-peaking as we called it kind of
works here too you can scout out some
danger zones without actually being in
danger unless you know someone drill
charges you but still beyond that a lot
of the combat kind of feels the same
besides the odd perspective shift from
third to first person whenever you aim
if you were wondering how to shoulder
swap on my default controls it was
simply clicking down the sticks you
should definitely take advantage of this
because if you don't shoulder swap you
are at a massive disadvantage on every
left-hand corner because the camera by
default sits over your right shoulder
meaning you have to rotate your
character much further to see around
you know i mean aside from a pretty
crummy ui and the unnecessary
third-person mode which we'll get into
later in another video and all that
confusing progression
i have to say that personally i'm
actually having a blast with modern
warfare 2's beta so far and i hope you
will too stay tuned to gamespot as aaron
samson jake decker and myself are going
to be diving into modern warfare hard
we've got some excellent videos cooking
up for you all including a proper
in-depth post-mortem on all the good the
bad and the ugly from that open beta if
you see me in the lobby on ps5 xbox or
pc say what's up
until next time
[Music]
you